what are our 10 15 looks good i just
continuations of our 2014 but nothing
has changed glasses match our
personalities my sets this mug is
British use it 40 minds seemingly
transparent but kind of dirty mine's got
one long leg hi guys welcome to this
video
I'm here with Hannah Mary Hart hello ah
yeah we said no relation what's that fry
Tom but funny no there's something else
that has no relation in there okay and
Ashley
there is a hater I saw on Instagram
because I started following Madi from
Dance Moms
um maybe weirdest choice of my life G is
in the new CEO music video and I mean we
all watched the first mom she was in
heaven also mamrie Hart did maybe the
best recreation of that music video on
stage at a live show
I'm a gifted woman there's a brand new
music video al elastic heart it spelled
no it's not oh no it's not okay I
thought that we because it kind of all
pertains to all of us that we should
review this for the very first time but
just wait are they taking okay oh my god
you think see I thought Shia because our
main four system like I do things in my
song yeah God got that Rupali shine its
not niku writing nude dirty - Meghan
looks like Max go swish oh this is so
uncomfortable already she's happening
already this is art I like to hear a
bunch of dirty Underpants she's only got
like two moves
it is so you guys I wonder are we being
pranks please rick roll us please rick
roll this uh in the first video it
looked like a little girl who was
abandoned by her parents so is that
supposed to be her like dashing out on
her dad whoa oh my god maybe like a male
amazing amazing
that makes it so less creepy I give
myself hold you oh he's very strong
crazy man
yeah laundry budget really oh I took a
weird turn
jzuk come with me I'm your dad come with
me I'm your daddy
take you away from here she's like yeah
and you're like Shh come with me we'll
get you a better wig
just imagine Abby Lee off to the side
watching this purple but is watching
doing this she's always like I Know Why
the Caged Bird Sings she's like get me
out of this is Kate could have gotten
out the whole time she's that tiny she
was trapped in her own cage oh god I
wish you did that the whole like fake
blow-up a middle finger at it yeah oh
I'm all enough to get away from him and
still be okay you guys I'm sorry this is
a very rough sort of it's grace he's
trying to that's my Shyam
he wasn't even Stephen he did take him
with her again should get a commission
because you're bad
yeah you can't be cleansed do you see
those cultural this is about how you can
only save yourself you've gotta let go
psycho guys yeah let's have some
resolution here what we did a sound guy
shouldn't break charge Oh God this is
last year but this year on its grace
yeah different show why were they so
dirty though oh never fighting for a
loan the only time I've ever seen Shia
LaBeouf I seem twice a person really one
time it was at a vegan restaurant and I
go part and he came in to get to go food
and he was wearing a karate key branded
you and I cannot done
I get four scars